la sologne terres humides au sol ingrat
essentiellement favorable à la forêt
elle a longtemps eu une réputation de
pauvreté gibier et miel champignons
poissons des temps composaient le menu
quotidien
mais à cela se rajoute est un élément
essentiel aujourd'hui quasi oubliée la
châtaigne appeler une époque l'arbre à
pain cultivé sur des milliers d'hectares
le châtaignier assurer la prospérité des
villages tout au long des 18 et 19ème
siècle au point d'accueillir et nourrir
des centaines de beaucerons les années
de mauvaises récoltes céréalières
nous sommes à y voit le marron pierre
fondateur du conservatoire de la
châtaigneraie solognote accueille
aujourd'hui un groupe d'étude
aujourd'hui un peu états généraux du
conservatoire de la châtaigneraie pour
identifier nos variétés d'une manière
scientifique
c'est à dire qu'on fait appel aux
compétences d'un castano log du
berrichon qui a l'expérience des
variétés locales pour appliquer une
méthode qu'il a déjà appliqué pour
essayer de que la connaissance
traditionnelle qui passe de bouche à
oreille devienne une connaissance
scientifique
on a sur la commune entre 800 et 1000
châtaignier identifié encore 150 200 qui
sont productifs donc des arbres
vénérables jusqu'à 8 mètres de
circonférence
donc c'est des arbres qui sont
acclimatées depuis trois à quatre cents
ans donc ça a un intérêt pour les
générations futures
imaginons y voit le marron voilà deux
siècles 5000 châtaignier sur 600
hectares greffer puis planté tous les 17
m il accueillait entre eux des pommiers
du seigle ou du blé noir cet immense
verger a disparu il ne reste plus que
des parcelles éparses entretenue par des
passionnés attaché à l'identité du lieu
mais aussi conscient d intérêt
biologique et économique en tant qu
apiculteurs professionnels
le châtaignier nous intéresse pour sa
floraison sa production de nectar dans
région centre le miel de châtaignier
représente à peu près 25% de la
production totale donc c'est très loin
d'être négligeable c'est une production
ni est très intéressante
ce qui peut être intéressant justement
ces deux
d'ajouter en fait à la production elle
la production la châtaigne complètement
compatibles avec l'emploi du temps de
l'apiculture pour claude devenue au fil
de ses recherches un spécialiste apporte
ses connaissances aux jeunes
conservatoire solognot dans le berry il
a dénombré 18 variétés de châtaigniers à
y voir déjà six sont répertoriés chaque
variété a son importance
d'où l'idée de les conserver le
conservatoire a surtout servir a gardé
un exemplaire
les reichel variété et ça peut servir
après pour créer de nouvelles variétés
créer de nouvelles variétés c'est
l'objectif de la pépinière du
conservatoire 150 jeunes châtaignier
issus de sologne qualité garante de leur
adaptation serviront de porte greffes
qui veut dire un châtaignier c'est comme
un pommier
quand ces sauvages ça produit un peu
n'importe quoi et des choses pas
nécessairement très comestible
donc il ya besoin pour transmettre les
qualités d'un fruit de passer par le la
technique de la greffe
alors la chute des fruits elle est
précoce le recensement commence position
gps sol caractéristiques mesures
physiques photo tout ce qui peut
permettre d'établir qu'il s'agit bien
d'une variété est consigné ses variétés
un goût différent
une aptitude particulière pour un
produit transformé et à partir de là on
peut créer de l'économie
délocalisables puisque c'est des
produits de terroir qui sont ancrés dans
leur terroir qui sont parfaitement
adaptées aux conditions locales aux
conditions climatiques aux conditions de
sol et les gens ont souvent le savoir
faire pour les mettre en valeur
le conservatoire devrait permettre de
mieux cerner et protéger ce patrimoine
fruitier solognot comme l'italie le
portugal ou plus proches l'ardèche la
sologne pourrait peut-être devenir
productrice de châtaignes produits
alimentaires de premier choix dans tous
les cas qu'ils soient économiques ou
écologiques les enjeux autour du
châtaignier aurons une véritable
influence sur le paysage de sologne